hey Ryan right and I'm Jerry we're gonna
check out the trailer today for 99 homes
but a [ __ ] ain't one
no no this is an Andrew Garfield movie
nothing about this
neither do I accept that Andrew Garfield
was fired from spider-man yeah okay yeah
I guess no it's pretty evident we have a
fire this is a different video Jerry
don't bring it up sorry I was that
language including some
let's get cooking sheriff's are here why
are they here
my name's Rick Carver I'm a licensed
real estate broker this home has been
foreclosed on I love you your mom and
your son to step off the property this
is not your own mr. Cardew you have two
minutes is that right okay don't say it
for a while just couple nice I got no
choice you kick me out yesterday I
didn't kick you out the bank did you do
construction
I'll pay $50 cash are you kidding me $50
soon be a joke to you son you're doing
with him
gotta work you know on the home back
don't get emotional about real estate
that's my family home if you want I need
to know that I have someone who can
handle any situation 24/7 you think
notices on my window you work for me
your mind
do you want to double what you made
we're stealing is this steel feels a bit
like trouble what do you think it was
going to mean working for me
mr. Tanner hate safe near eviction is
scheduled for the day so I cannot is
this all worth it don't be soft
Keep America didn't flying rat's ass
about you or me who can America doesn't
bail out the losers
Oh
America was built by bailing out winners
a nation of the winners
by the
only one in the hundreds gonna get on
that arts our every other poor souls
gonna drown geez intense yeah it's very
happy intense is the word I would use
it's interesting watching this trailer
at this particular moment in my life I
feel like I'll might have a slightly
different opinion about this not a
different opinion but maybe a little bit
of a different point of view towards the
situation I was watching this
documentary yesterday called I am Tom
Shadyac is actually the one who created
this documentary like the first
half-hour is really talking about how we
have we feel like we've been programmed
and like created certain values towards
things that define us you know things
we've heard before like how money
defines us and the American wealth and
he was talking about himself and his own
personal experiences saying how he
obtained that wealth and it really
didn't do anything and which we've heard
a billion times but we're still under
this preconceived notion that making
money is at the end of the day what
really matters but then it's like a lot
of us will get there anyway and then go
know what I heard was true it doesn't
really matter versus human nature which
they broke down human nature and Charles
Darwin said this he's a smart one he's a
smart one
he said sympathy is the strongest
instinct in human nature so that's how
you can transcend is like if you have a
certain level of sympathy you know you
can realize the value of community and
sort of yeah after one another and
that's how you keep the most people you
know to get right right because one
thing they were talking about is how a
lot of us are under this impression that
were programmed to be like territory you
only kind of unlike animalistic like
behaviors but when they were really
breaking it down in this documentary
talking with like scientist
psychologists a whole bunch of different
experts you real don't you John in the
middle of my conversation don't you John
in the middle of my conversation that
conversation don't you yawn monologue in
my monologue in human nature what they
really discover is that human nature is
to be cooperative and supportive to work
together you know like rather than being
opponents
we kind of view everything through
competition now it the actual nature of
us is to be like collaborative you know
that's why YouTube's great because we
collab with people it got me thinking
about that
because in this movie it's a hard job
but Andrew Garfield has to do don't chew
a yawn in the middle of my monologue
they're chewy yawn in the middle of my
mumble because Andrew Garfield is put in
an interesting position where he had
this horrible thing happened to him for
closure and then he has to now do the
job that has like destroy him in order
to take care of his family when these
things I was thinking of that got
brought up it was through Michael
Shannon's character who I loved as an
actor everyone knows he's like a
fantastic guy yeah if you don't know
that by now you're not it on the loop
here because yeah Michael Shannon
everyone knows Michael Shannon is good
he looks fantastic in this he is great
for intimidating characters and I just
want him to play like I want him to be
in a movie where he plays like a pair of
brothers with with Rainn Wilson yeah
just feel like I'm in number three Harry
and Lloyds lost brother
but I feel like this movie is dealing
with themes along lines without what he
was causing me to think about these
homes are getting foreclosure on and he
used to be a part of that community and
he's there getting screwed over by this
guy he was like how exactly was Michael
Shannon digging him over me he sort of
brings him on as like a cheap labor
basically anyway I'll pay you and you
should you know sort of be thankful for
the fact that you're getting paid at all
and I guess you know he's into some sort
of lucrative stuff and sort of expects
Andrew Garfield to just keep yeah he's
got a little niche we don't know the
specifics of what it is but I may have
missed he's equipping him with a gun and
[ __ ] yeah so I get the sense that he's
into some less than savory acting right
all right I get that impression to the
way his character you know speaks and
acts it doesn't seem like he would it
would be beyond him to you know also
have some criminal activity on the side
or stuff this sort of tries to skirt you
know beneath yeah I think he's just an
unsavory cat yeah Michael Shannon kind
of seems like the Gordon Gekko of real
estate
it forces Andrew Garfield to sort of be
very cutthroat and just like you know I
have to do what I have to do survive
regardless of where I can
from yeah looking at this trailer with
the critical opinions like Andrew
Garfield will make you come out of joy
Michael Shannon will cause you to take a
[ __ ] out of pure bliss he's like crazy
yes things up saying about these dudes I
almost don't want to imagine the state
of bliss that would cause somebody just
to kind of relax and be okay just [ __ ]
it looks good though looks intense
it looks emotionally rewarding I feel
like it's the kind of movie that can go
do boo and like feel some emotions you
know like like oh I'm feeling a little
bit blocked right now so I want to feel
it's gonna get some emotions out
certainly looks heavy you know heavy did
you pee on again during my voice no I
mean it certainly looks heavy and it
certainly looks like you know the kind
of movie that's gonna ask some questions
about society yeah anyway guys thanks
for tuning in to the real rejects if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects subscribe
you can check out Jerry's playlist on
reasons to Jerry movie reviews and
podcast ink ass right and you can follow
us on Facebook Instagram and Twitter
mainly Instagram and Vine actually that
that's where you'll want to follow us
because if we get enough followers a
week and yet product placement people
for things such as spoons just just in
general yes moons are great spoons
um you can drink soup with them you can
eat cereal and if you ever want to try
an experiment we know you do you put
this spoon up against your left nut
right here just hold it you cup it with
the spoon and you get a lighter right
and then you just burn the kind of like
you're cooking nothing but on the spoon
but instead you're doing on your balls
right and then your lady sucks it into
burns like ice